[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi,
and welcome to episode
number 71 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc, and I'm here
with my colleague, Mark Mandel.
Hey mark.
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm good,
thanks, Francesc.
How are you doing today?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very
good, very happy.
Felling lonely.
Where are you?
MARK MANDEL: I am in Vancouver.
It's cold here.
I left sunny San Francisco--
[LAUGHING] to come to Vancouver.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Yeah, that will teach you.
Anyway--
Today, we're going to have
a pretty cool episode.
We have one of our dear
developer advocates
from our team at Google
Platform, Yufeng Guo,
to talk about the Cloud
Machine Learning Engine.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, he's going
to come have a chat with us
about TensorFlow,
machine learning,
how to do it in the cloud.
How can you use it?
What is this crazy thing?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, it's
a very interesting topic,
and the cool thing is that
basically makes TensorFlow,
like basically, as a service.
You don't need to have
to install anything.
It's just-- it's there.
So it's very, very useful.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, and if
you have huge data sets,
it's very, very useful.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh Yeah,
especially for that.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
And then after that,
we're going to have
our question of the week,
which I think you're going
to know a whole lot about.
We're going to talk about
API keys and Cloud Endpoints.
When do I need them?
When do I want them?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yup, it's
a pretty common question.
So hopefully will be pretty
useful for a lot of people.
But before that, I think
we have today a bunch
of different cool
things of the week.
The first one coming from you.
You added the
Kubernetes 1.6, and I
don't know much about what's
needed in Kubernetes 1.6.
So why don't you
tell us a little bit.
MARK MANDEL: Sweet.
So Kubernetes 1.6--
I'm a huge Kubernetes
fan, as many people know.
There is a huge
amount of stuff going
on in 1.6, which is great.
Huge, huge scale increase,
which I think is really cool.
We're up from 2,000 nodes
supports to 5,000 nodes,
and 150,000 nodes support.
Overview, at a
high level, there's
new stuff around security.
There's a whole bunch of
advanced scheduling features,
storage provision, and more.
There's some pretty
cool stuff going on.
If you want to know more about
it, go to the Kubernetes blog.
They are doing five
days of Kubernetes 1.6.
They're up to day
three currently.
It all deep dives into
all the new stuff.
They've covered
dynamic provisioning,
some scalability updates,
advance scheduling.
Day four and five,
don't know what's
coming, but pretty excited
to see what's coming.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Maybe we should have someone
from the Kubernetes thing
to tell us a little bit
about all the new things.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely,
we should totally do that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And we have
then one more cool thing.
I'm going to go with
that one, which is I'm
a big fan of Google App Engine.
And one of the
flavors of App Engine
is App Engine
flexible environment.
And the new thing is that it's
now available in Europe West
Region.
So if you've ever tried
to run Node or Ruby,
or any of those languages
that run on App Engine Flex--
So yeah, now if you're
one of those people that
run Ruby or Node, and you want
to run them on App Engine Flex,
you can now run them on
your Europe West, which
means that if you have
customers in there
you have a way shorter latency,
which is always a nice thing
to have.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Super excited to have
that in the region.
I'm sure there's plenty
of people in Europe
and surrounding areas who
are very excited as well.
Cool.
So finally, cool
things of the week.
Just want to say
a quick shout out
to one of the gentlemen who
joined us on the podcast
at the Community Summit
[INAUDIBLE] Next.
I'm probably going to massacre
his name, Kalev Leetaru.
I think I got that
vaguely right.
He wrote a series of
articles for Forbes magazine,
now Forbes online,
talking about Google Cloud
Next, his experiences, and what
his views and his viewpoints
are.
It's fairly long, but
there's some really
cool and interesting
content in there,
where he talks about security,
scale, learning as a service,
much like what we're
talking about today.
Lots of really good stuff.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, and we have
links to every single one of the
three articles that he wrote--
no, the last three
articles, on the show notes.
So if you're interested
in going there,
just go check it out, and
have a long and nice read.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
So why don't we
go talk to Yufeng?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
am very happy today
to welcome to the podcast
one more of our dear
fellow developer
advocates, Yufeng Guo.
How are you doing?
YUFENG GUO: I'm
great, thank you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And we have you
here to talk about many things,
but mostly machine learning.
But before we start
doing that, why don't you
tell us a little
bit about yourself,
and what you do at Google.
YUFENG GUO: Sure.
So I'm like you
guys, a developer
advocate on the
Google Cloud team,
and lately I've been
focusing on a lot of machine
learning stuff.
And what that means
is, on the Cloud side,
I've been talking
about and playing
with the Cloud Machine
Learning Engine, which
recently went to GA.
And also as a corollary to that,
a lot of work with TensorFlow.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
So we said a lot
of products there.
But this is probably
a very big question,
but what is machine learning?
YUFENG GUO: Yeah.
So machine learning--
the what is it question
is definitely a big one
that, kind of, everybody's
wondering right now.
And in general, I--
my short version,
of what is machine
learning, is--
I define it with
five or six words.
It's using examples
to answer questions,
or answering questions
using many examples.
So I think that's five words.
So then all of-- and I've
distilled it down to that,
you know.
So all the words are
kind of important.
Using-- you want to
answer questions.
We're not just using machine
learning for the sake of it.
It's the purpose of it is to
answer the questions that you
have, and then we want to
use examples to do that.
So that means you need to have
examples to show your system,
and you need lots of them.
So questions.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
instead of, basically like,
writing an algorithm,
what you do is you just
throw data at something.
Like this is how you're
supposed to do it,
and the machine learns,
that's the machine
learning part of it.
YUFENG GUO: Right, and
another way to kind
of visualize that is to think
of traditional programming,
as you writing a bunch of rules.
You can think of it almost like
the flow of a river, right.
So the information flows
from the top of your program
downwards, goes to
different functions,
flows through if
statements and form loops.
And then the output of
your various functions,
and your program does something.
Right, so--
A machine learning
algorithm is kind
of doing the same
thing with data.
You're writing, you're
creating some structure,
and all of this data
is flowing through
and all this math is happening.
And then on the other side
of that there's some output.
But there is this
additional step beforehand,
where you need to write code
to make that something, where
the data flows through.
So you need to
make the structures
that the data will flow
through, in the first place.
Whereas, with normal
programming that is your code.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Interesting.
So given all of that
context, where is TensorFlow.
YUFENG GUO: Right.
So TensorFlow then is
an open source library
that Google released a
little over a year ago,
in November of 2015.
And it's an open source library
written at its core in c++
and c, and then has a Python
API and now a couple of APIs
in other languages.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: There's a
go-- there's a go buy me.
YUFENG GUO: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: [LAUGHING]
YUFENG GUO: And so
that's a library
for facilitating the
creation of these structures,
that we were talking
about earlier,
that the data
would flow through.
We call them graphs.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So all right, say I'm
like, yes machine learning
and TensorFlow, but I don't
know where to apply it.
What are some common, or
like, regular type things
that people tend to do with
machine learning that people
could then apply it themselves?
YUFENG GUO: So the two or three
big categories of use cases
that we're seeing emerge is
image classification, data--
structured data classification
or regression, and finally,
something to the
effect of, time series.
So whether it's streaming
log data or videos or audio,
the time series where you care
about the previous data points,
those are kind of the
three broad categories
that we're seeing.
MARK MANDEL: So when
you say classification,
what does that actually
mean though, just
so people understand 100%.
YUFENG GUO: Right.
So classification is
where you put the data
into, kind of, different
buckets, different categories,
if you will.
And you could have as
few as two categories,
and those two could even be--
is it x?
Or is it not x?
It doesn't necessarily
have to be x and y.
Or it could be like, I'm
recognizing these pictures
as apples or other.
Doesn't necessarily have
to be apples or bananas.
And so the
classification has also
emerged as this place
where you end up
being able to put a lot
of problem sets into.
Like, you can fit
a lot of problems
into "the domain of
classification", quote unquote,
because you can also go
from not just two classes,
but many, many classes.
So you can, say, have 100
classes or even 1,000 classes.
So then you begin to
get into a situation
where you're able
to bucket things
into many, many
different buckets,
and that can also
be very powerful.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Can
you give an example
of-- like when you're saying
like 1,000 buckets, what kind
of application would do that?
YUFENG GUO: So one
classic example
is the Imagenet
Competition, which
is an international machine
learning competition
for image recognition.
So they provide 1,000
categories that you
as the machine learning
scientists, or the competitor,
need to create a machine
learning model which
will classify the input
data, or the pictures,
into the correct one of
these 1,000 categories.
So if you get a picture of
a specific breed of dog,
that might be a particular
category or bucket
in those thousands.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Interesting.
So what about when you have
something that is not really--
I'd say it's probably not a
classification problem, because
rather than having
a bunch of buckets,
however many you might have,
it is something continuous.
Like-- I don't know.
Like, it's something-- you're
trying to predict a value,
and it's a flow so, you know,
there's infinite technically.
Well, technically
not, but whatever.
YUFENG GUO:
Absolutely, and so that
is what is typically
referred to as regression.
So that's the other side
of this particular subset
of problems, where you are
trying to predict the value.
One example, that kind of
treads the line, is let's
say you had a machine
learning model
that took a bunch of inputs,
such as your diet, when
you went to sleep--
there's lots of these quantified
self tracking variables--
and tried to predict your age.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
I thought you were
going to say trying
to predict the day you die.
[LAUGHTER]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cause then--
MARK MANDEL: It's
the same thing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's
just that [INAUDIBLE]
YUFENG GUO: I'm pretty
sure, the day you die,
that's probably just a
random generator, x time
in the future.
So with that, what's tricky
about it is if you just
output a number, like
an integer number,
do you count that as
regression or classification?
Because, yeah, there
are a lot of ages,
right, one through something
on the order of 100.
But as we said, you could
pretty easily classify it
between 100 different things.
And maybe you say,
well I don't think
I can be as precise as
to say like, you know,
your age is 35.7 or
something like that.
But at the same time,
maybe you don't even
want to be as specific
as saying it's 35.
So then you get into saying
bucketing into different age
groups, and saying, OK you're
in the 18 to 25 age group.
And you got to think about
like surveys and things
like that operate in a sense.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
there's basically--
like there's
classification problems,
there's regression
problems, and then
something kind of
in the middle, where
you could choose going
one way or the other.
Are all of those problems
treatable with TensorFlow.
YUFENG GUO: Absolutely.
Absolutely.
TensorFlow is really meant
to be a general purpose
machine learning library.
And it's actually,
in some ways, broader
than that, because
all it's really doing
is creating this
graph, that we were
talking about earlier, where
all the numbers flow through.
And you can create that
to do anything you want.
You can have it do
math, just like addition
or multiplication, and
then compute, you know,
other kind of more
complicated math things
that are not machine learning.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Interesting.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
YUFENG GUO: That being said,
yeah, the high level tooling
around it that says
like, you know,
just make this thing for me.
That's all geared
toward machine learning.
But if you go into it and
you use some of the low level
tooling, where you can
really control the graph
and build it kind of from
scratch piece by piece,
you can build anything you want.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So I got a question.
So Americans are curious.
So we've seen examples,
like you said,
like where image classification
is a classification problem.
But like Francesc talked about
Martin's talk last episode,
and in that he was generating
stuff out of models
that he put TensorFlow into.
Like, basically, making
things sound like Shakespeare
or Shakespearean like text.
Where does that
kind of sit, where
it's like you're
generating stuff to seem
like similar other things.
Is that like predictive,
or what's the deal there?
YUFENG GUO: Yeah, absolutely.
So these generative models is
kind of a new, newish class
of machine learning--
algorithm machine
learning models.
And part of it is mapped to
the kind of traditional things
that we were talking about,
where you have this model--
in this particular case,
you're taking all the works
of Shakespeare, and putting
it, running through the model
so that the output
is this model that
can recognize whether something
is or isn't Shakespeare.
So that you could
give it some new text,
and then it will think of--
you know, run it through,
and then on the other side it'll
say, yes this is Shakespeare,
or no it's not Shakespeare.
Now in doing that,
you've basically
created a little system that
can also generate Shakespearean.
It knows what Shakespeare
is like, right.
It's encoded into that model.
And so then if you could
massage it in the right way
you can also have it output what
it thinks Shakespeare would be.
And another way-- another way
to think about or design that
would be to, say, give
it Shakespeare, and have
it learn-- this is more
of that sequencing model
that we were talking about,
the third kind of class where
you're looking at a
sequence of words.
So with Shakespeare
you have any writing
that's a sequence of words.
So you teach it
to say, OK I know
that after word a usually
there's either words b1, b2,
or b3, and then it's like c1,
c2, c3-- you know, these words.
And so these are like
the possible sequences.
So given some input it
can kind of continue.
And that's the exact
same idea and basis
for some of the audio models
that we see, like the music
related ones where you can
play the first few notes
and then it picks up for you.
It's just analyzing
the data that's
embedded in the music
signal, whether that's
just straight audio or
like something like MIDI.
MARK MANDEL: All right, cool.
So we've talked about TensorFlow
through the open source
project.
Let's talk about Cloud
Machine Learning Engine,
and like, what is that thing.
So can you tell us like
what's the difference,
or what is the Cloud
Machine Learning
Engine from a high level?
YUFENG GUO: So the Cloud
Machine Learning Engine
is really, at its core,
managed infrastructure
for running TensorFlow on
the Google Cloud Platform.
And so we'll break down
each of those points.
The part about it being
managed infrastructure,
the difference there
is it's not that you
need to spin up some
virtual machines,
allocate some storage
or persistent disk,
and then tell it, oh here's
where I want you to run things.
Right, it will do that for you.
It will spin up the machines.
It will make sure the right
libraries are installed etc.
And so you have this
managed infrastructure,
and you then just have to
give it your TensorFlow code.
And we have the G
Cloud command line
tool that will take care
of that for you as well.
The code goes up, and then
the machines are automatically
created for you, spun up,
and your code is loaded in.
And then it runs it for you.
And then when it's
done, that output
goes to Google Cloud Storage
where your data was as well.
And so you can define
all of those parameters,
including how many
machines, how powerful you
want those machines to be,
whether those machines should
have GPU attached to them etc.
But at the end of the
day, the code that you
write, the machine
learning code,
is just pure TensorFlow code.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So you mentioned the output.
What is the output?
Is that the prediction that
you make, or what is it?
YUFENG GUO: Usually,
in the first half
of the work that
you do, which is you
are training, the output of
that is the model itself.
So that's just a
file or a few files
that together define
that graph of, basically,
that mathematical kind of
model that can take an input
and generate the desired
output, usually a prediction.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
So that's what all
the people [INAUDIBLE]
like a neural network itself?
Is that what we're
talking about?
YUFENG GUO: Exactly.
So in the case of a neural
network, that file would just
be lots and lots of
numbers in its path
down into a binary
format, and you know,
you can pass in a picture
and it will tell you,
is it a kitten or
a puppy, right.
And so that first
step is just half
of the machine learning engine,
in that that's the training
half.
And the other half
of machine learning
is the answering of questions.
And so to facilitate that, you
have the prediction service.
So that's what I view as
another large chunk of it that
is often overlooked, because
so much emphasis is placed
on the training, because it is
the more challenging half by
and large.
But after you've
gathered all your data,
cleaned it, picked the right
model, tuned as parameters,
spent who knows how long
training it and waiting
for it to finish, the last
thing you want to be doing
is then going and looking up on
Stack Overflow, how exactly do
I spin up a web server
to wrap this model
to scale that server, logging,
quotas, all the good stuff.
Especially for someone who
is well-versed in machine
learning, that tends to be
your data scientist or machine
learning researcher,
they are oftentimes not
as experienced in
managing infrastructure.
They might not, because they're
spending all their time in kind
of machine learning land.
They're not over here learning
about Kubernetes, and Docker,
and scalable systems,
and things like that.
So the prediction service
helps you with that.
It says, just give us the model,
that folder with the couple
files that was output
from your training--
MARK MANDEL: And it gives you
a rest endpoint or something
like that?
YUFENG GUO: Exactly, it
gives you a scalable rest
endpoint that is
deployed for you,
and it also takes
care of versioning,
so that you can
say, OK I'm going
to make a model, my
puppies or kittens model.
And this is going to be v1.
And then later when
you turn a new model,
you can say this is v2.
And you have both of them, and
you can switch between them
as like which ones default.
MARK MANDEL: It's like App
Engine and Points merge
together for machine learning.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, Spherical.
YUFENG GUO: Yeah, so I think
that's a really neat feature
in that those two
steps are decoupled,
thanks to TensorFlow, in that
you have this model's file--
model file output.
Which means that if
you do local training,
you output that same exact file,
because Cloud Machine Learning
Engine is just
running TensorFlow.
The outputs of
training in the cloud,
and outputs of training
on your laptop,
are pretty much the same.
It's just a question of, do
you want it to be distributed?
Do you want it to be faster?
And so that output,
then you can just
push or upload those
files to the cloud
yourself, and then put
it to the prediction.
And so you could train
locally and predict
in a scalable way on the cloud.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So I see the value
of serving those models,
that prediction on the cloud,
because, you know, you
want people to access it.
What is the benefit of
training on the cloud,
rather than training
on your own laptop?
YUFENG GUO: That's a
really good question.
So when training
on the cloud, there
are a couple of reasons
you might want to do it,
on both sides, right.
If you're just working with a
small data set, and you know,
you're OK with the
performance on your laptop,
then by all means train on your
laptop, train on your desktop,
train on your local GPU
cluster, if you have one, right.
But when you get
into situations where
your data sizes are too big to
be stored on your one machine--
and that can be a number
of different thresholds,
because you know, if I
just have my laptop here;
on my laptop maybe it just
has one terabyte of disk.
And so something
less than a terabyte,
but more than a couple
of hundred gigs,
I probably don't want to
be wrangling that around.
Maybe what I'll do,
though, is take a section.
I'll take a representative
sample of that data.
Put that on my laptop,
and train that locally,
so I can get the code
working correctly.
That's a nice and
fast iteration cycle.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It was
like your development
cycle is on the computer.
YUFENG GUO: Right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But
then when you actually
train, you will not
turn on your computer,
because it's too slow or--
YUFENG GUO: So usually, yeah,
if your data set is really quite
large, it can be too slow.
MARK MANDEL: What is large?
Can you give us a rule of thumb.
I know obviously ballpark
figuresish, but where would
you say that line
would be in terms of--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: How many
kittens versus puppies
are we talking about here?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
YUFENG GUO: Yeah, because--
and before I try to come
up with a number here,
there's so many other parameters
that play around that data,
because it depends on
how big your network is
that you're trying to train.
How big are these images
that you're pushing in?
Whether or not you're
going to downsampled them
to a lower resolution will
also make a big difference.
And then finally just your
general hardware and ops
configurations around
transfer speed.
So a lot of times you
end up with situations
where you're IO bound.
Sometimes it's compute bound,
and then sometimes it's
kind of like memory bound, just
like shuffling things around.
There are situations
where people
have had to move to distributed
CPUs, because the data could
not fit on the 6 gigs or 12
gigs of RAM on the GPU card.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Wow.
OK.
YUFENG GUO: Like they had
to hold all that at once.
I'm not saying that the
whole data set was big
and that, because of course
a lot of times they are.
But like for the computation
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
--hold, you know, over
six or 12 gigs of data.
It's like, that's crazy.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So you
didn't answer the question.
ALL: [LAUGHING]
MARK MANDEL: Nicely done.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: From your--
Right, yeah.
Very developer advocate.
But so give us that one concrete
example that you've done.
How big was the data?
And how long it took to
train on your laptop,
or how long it took to
train on Cloud ML engine?
YUFENG GUO: So one
good example of that
was when I was training a
transfer learning model for--
actually, I was running
through one of our code labs.
It was for image
model for recognizing
five different types
of flowers, and--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
is more than I can.
YUFENG GUO: They were
really common flowers
like roses and tulips and
lilies, and things like that.
So that data set was I
believe it was 200,000--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Images?
YUFENG GUO: Images.
They were images.
And training locally,
my CPU it was
taking on the order
of like half an hour.
So it was getting to the point
I was like, well I don't really
want to be burnt taking this.
I can't use my
browser, it's slow,
it's burning from my
battery, the fan is spinning.
And so pushing
that to the cloud,
I was able-- it was coming
down to, not including
kind of spin up time.
And that's the other
thing I will get into.
It was taking about
like 15ish minutes,
so half-- but there was
like not like that powerful
of a configuration.
You know, I think it was
just like, basically,
a fancy desktop.
And so moving from the
laptop to a fancy desktop,
you know, you've got some boost,
but you know, nothing crazy.
I think the crazy
scaling factors
happen when you have truly
tremendous data sets.
You know, maybe
on the order of--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Terabytes.
YUFENG GUO: Possibly terabytes.
Like hundreds of gigs
to multiple terabytes
worth of data and up.
And the data size is a really
hard number to really just go
against, because if you have
image data, it's bigger.
If you have logs files,
it will be smaller,
and you can fit a lot of
log files in 10,000 jpgs.
And those log files
are rich data.
And so pushing
that all through--
and if it's a complex model
can also take a long time.
So it's not a easy
kind of rule of thumb.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So I'm curious about, so,
TensorFlow, what it is.
It's an open source
library, right?
YUFENG GUO: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It is not
the only one, I'm assuming.
What is-- like could you give
a little bit of a comparison?
Why would you use TensorFlow
rather than something else?
And I personally
don't know any other.
So I'm going to let you
answer that question.
YUFENG GUO: So with TensorFlow
the advantages there
I think are primarily
around the ability
to go from research
to production easily.
In the past and in a
lot of other fields
as well, where you have
research and production as kind
of separate parts
of the industry,
you end up with a situation
where the research is
doing things in one language
or writing their own custom
frameworks.
And then to implement
it, to make it run fast,
you rewrite everything in c++.
And what's great about
TensorFlow is that
the underlying implementation
is already in c++,
but you get to work on it via
Python, or in your case Go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I have
not tried it yet, but yeah.
YUFENG GUO: So that allows
you to have flexibility
while maintaining
high performance.
And one of the things in
the TensorFlow 1.0 release,
which came out in
February 15th, is
the release of XLA, which
is still experimental.
And it stands for
accelerated linear algebra,
and I know everybody loves
talking about linear algebra.
But in a nutshell, what it
does is it takes your trained
graph or model--
and think about
compiling that down.
So instead of
representing it with c++,
it actually represents
it with a machine code.
So it makes it--
MARK MANDEL: Like another layer.
YUFENG GUO: Exactly.
Or another layer
of optimization.
So instead of running a
compiler on your code,
right-- think about
compiling a code,
and now it's really fast, right.
What we're going to
do is we're going
to compile the graph,
which in our analogy
is kind of the code.
That's what the data
is flowing through.
We're gonna compile
that down to machine
code, or something
like machine code,
so that the data
can run even faster.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
That's very amazing.
MARK MANDEL: That is very cool.
I'm curious now.
So as well, what's been
the most interesting
or crazy or wonderful machine
learning thing that you've seen
people do with either
TensorFlow or machine learning.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I have an
answer to that question,
but you go first.
[LAUGHING]
YUFENG GUO: Sounds good.
So I think one of the most
relevant in terms of real world
applications of machine
learning, that I've seen,
is the recent
research that came out
around skin cancer and
diabetic retinopathy detection.
And there's many groups
doing similar work
for other areas of medicine
as well, because these
are areas where you
have a task that
is highly sophisticated,
well-defined and repeatable,
and right now is
limited to the kind
of domain of trained experts
who are human and thus
subject to tiredness,
sleepiness,
grumpiness, things like that.
And so having a machine
that can at least do
that initial first
pass for you is great.
It's sort of like you
don't have a traffic cop
standing at every single
intersection waiting
for someone to run
that red light.
You have a camera.
It will flag them for
you, and then maybe you
have a human at the end of
the chain that says like,
oh no that was fine.
He was turning on a red.
Or something like that.
But you know, it helps
you get that first pass.
And so in the example with
skin cancer, you know,
you have very good detection
rates that are actually
comparable to professionals.
But even if you didn't.
Even for domains where
it's not perfect,
I think it would be
interesting to see,
because image recognition
and computer vision
are kind of more advanced than
some other areas of machine
learning right now.
It would be really interesting
to see those applications
in places where it's
not as perfect, as
long as you can have
a human in the chain,
because if it's not perfect
and you're making mistakes,
then it can lead
to bad experience.
MARK MANDEL: I guess it
also gets interesting too
where personnel on ground is
probably less easy to get to
or able to reach to.
And so if you can make
that first pass in a way
that can be automated,
or something like that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah I can imagine,
if you're able to create
basically like mobile app
that anywhere in
the world can use.
Like if you're a doctor
that doesn't have access
to that training.
That is pretty amazing.
YUFENG GUO: Absolutely.
And in certain countries
around the world
there are certain
types of doctors
that are in super
high demand, and you
have just lines going down
the street around the corner.
And they only come
every once in a while,
and you know they can't even
see everybody in time so--
and then you can
imagine like the quality
of care in those
kinds of scenarios
where you just kind of
churning through everybody
is not going to be very high.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
MARK MANDEL: You had something.
What was it, Francesc?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, my
answer is way more lame, but--
[LAUGHING] my
answer is actually,
one of our colleagues,
she used to be a developer
advocate, Julia Fiorelli.
She gave a really good
talk on Huggable or Not,
which basically was a machine.
It was a neural network
trained with a bunch of images,
and telling that
either it was huggable,
like you should hug it, or not.
And the coolest part is it shows
an octopus like, you should not
hug an octopus.
And then he shows
like a little plush
is like, you should
definitely hug the plush.
And then it shows
a plush octopus,
and machine learning
algorithm was actually
able to tell that, yeah
you should definitely
hug a octopus plush.
Like, oh that is really cool.
So yeah, you know, it's
like it's not saving lives,
[LAUGHING] but it
was pretty cool.
YUFENG GUO: Yeah
I mean, blending
this kind of knowledge, and
generalizing to examples
that it hasn't seen before,
is one of the strengths
of machine learning.
Especially in the
area of deep learning,
you're building something that
is generalizing beyond just
like memorizing things.
Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So we're
kind of running out of time,
and I'd like to give you
the opportunity to give us
anything else that you have.
Is there anything else
that you'd like to mention?
YUFENG GUO: We recently hired
Fei-fei Lee, from Stamford,
and she is just awesome.
I believe the exact
quote from Next
was, "she is another
bad ass woman".
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
She's a bad ass woman.
YUFENG GUO: Absolutely.
And so between that and the
recent acquisition of Kaggle,
it really feels
like there's kind
of this gathering of
forces within Google
and within the community.
That is kind of propelling
the machine learning community
forward, and creating an
ecosystem where people
can get started quickly, can
run their systems cheaply fast,
and have the support that
they need to grow and interact
with their peers.
So like the Kaggle acquisition
really helps further
a platform that has already
gained a lot of traction.
Kaggle was definitely
kind of the place
for data scientists
and data sets to live.
And having that be in
a position to continue
to grow, and be kind of
funded and not go away,
is really fantastic.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Since
you mentioned them,
if anyone from Kaggle wants
to come to the podcast,
they're definitely invited.
And if, Fei-fei, you're
listening to this--
MARK MANDEL: You are definitely,
definitely invited here.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Definitely,
definitely invited.
So please, please.
Well you know how to reach us.
So thank you so much for
your time, your thing.
That was a super
interesting conversation.
YUFENG GUO: Yeah, thank
you, Francesc, Mark.
This was great.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thanks.
Thanks so much to you.
Thanks for taking the time to
explain all the cool things
that you can do with Cloud
Machine Learning Engine.
This is the fourth
time I say that.
ALL: [LAUGHING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I'm still having
an issue of engine part of it.
I knew a lot about TensorFlow.
Like I've been watching
some of the talks
that we said that Martin
Gardner gave at Cloud Next.
Amazing talks, and it was
a very interesting thing
to add a little bit of, OK,
so on top of that, what is
Cloud Machine Learning Engine.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely,
totally agreed.
I don't get to dabble very
much with the ML stuff.
So super happy to have Yufeng
on to help educate us and talk
to us all about
the whole platform.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
I think it's time
to go to our
question of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so I think
this is an interesting one,
and I think probably
right up your alley.
So when talking about
like rest end points,
often I hear about these
things called API keys.
So what are API
keys, and how can I
use them on cloud end points?
Like what would I use them
for, and why would I use them?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
So the first part
of the question
is, what is an API key?
An API key is a key that you
use to authorize some API call.
And the important thing is
that this is authorization, not
really authentication.
These are not really secure.
You should not use them
as a security measure
really, because they're actually
kind of easy to intercept.
Once they're
intercepted, they do not
have any expiration time.
So you know, it's like once you
have it, you have it forever.
Unless it's of
course banned, which
means that for
some things they're
very useful, because
they're very easy to use.
Basically in general,
you just add them
as a parameter to a query.
Like very often that you
will see them on the URL.
They can be very
useful for service
to servers authentication
for instance.
Specifically, when
one of the service
is not really behaving
in the name of a user,
but just as a project.
You have a project acting
as a project itself.
That is one of
the ways to do it.
Very simple to do.
And especially when you
actually trust the whole chain,
and is a chain like over
HTTPS or something where,
basically, the content is not
shown to everyone looking.
The other option is to use
authentication tokens, right,
which is off to stuff like that.
Which is way more advanced, but
also it's harder to maintain.
It's harder to use.
Like, I don't know if
you've implemented off
to dance on a server.
MARK MANDEL: No.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It is not fun.
It is really not fun.
It is the kind of
thing that makes
you love Firebase authentication
stuff, like that really.
So when to use API keys.
Well, the answer
is pretty simple.
The answer is whenever you
authenticating project, not
a user, right,
because you don't want
to have an API key per user.
It's per project, per group,
of like an app for instance.
If you have an
mobile app, you might
want to use an API key there.
And also when you're
able to make sure
that is actually hidden
enough, or secured enough,
that people will be
able to find it easy.
And no matter when
you're using an API key,
those APIs keys should never
be the only security measure
that you have.
MARK MANDEL: All right, cool.
So it sounds like
API keys are just
a nice, light way to give
people access to your APIs,
but also be able to determine
who is accessing your APIs,
unlike on one of behalf they
are accessing your APIs.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, basically.
So if you want to control
like security, like hardcore
security, it's not
the way to do it.
But if you want to control
things like quotas or basically
having a better way of tracking
who is using what, something
that you can grab from the
logs and stuff like that,
API key's great for that.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
And so cloud end points,
they give you an easy way
to set up API keys,
is that right?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh
yes, it's super simple.
So the cool thing is
that basically you can--
once you deploy cloud end
points API on your project,
then only the API keys
created from a project
that have access to
that API are valid.
Which means that then what you
can do is you create your API,
you deploy it, and then
you create as many API keys
as you want from your
project directly,
and then you can share
those, which is very simple.
Or even better,
you share your API
with whoever you want to
give access to your API
then they activate their
API on their project
like you would
activate any other API,
like let's say Compute Engine
or Kubernets, Container Engine.
All of those are different APIs.
Just go to the API manager.
You activate it, and then
you can create a new API
from that project directly.
So basically you're
able to expose an API as
if you were Google, basically.
And anyone that has access to
that API can create an API key,
and get direct
access to your API.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Sounds great.
I can't wait to get
started with API keys.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
So I think it's time
to finish the episode.
But before we say goodbye,
you are right now in Canada.
What are you up to, and
what are you up to after?
MARK MANDEL: So I'm in Canada.
By the time this episode airs,
I will have already spoken
at the Unity Meetup, but I will
be doing the Polyglot Vancouver
Meetup the day after.
So I'll be talking about
your GRPC and Kubernetes.
After that I am doing an east
coast game conference, and then
Vector conference, talking about
getting stuff with Kubernetes.
Shortly after that,
I want to highlight
doing a game jam for play
crafting with Extra Life.
So its a two weekend
special event to help
raise money for UCSF
children's hospitals.
So it's going to be on May 5th
and 7th, here in San Francisco.
The URL will be
in the show notes.
What are you up to?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm
basically on my way to China.
I'm living next week for
GopherCon China, in Shanghai.
It's going to be pretty amazing.
I'm going to be also
organizing a couple of Meetups.
Then after that, I
will be in New York.
And I actually got
confirmed that I
will be speaking at the
Google Developer Group Meetup
in New York.
We have our dear friend, Brett.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yep, we're going
to be having a
serverless Meetup.
He will be talking
about cloud functions,
and I will be talking
about cloud endpoints.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And Go, obviously.
MARK MANDEL: Obviously.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
then on May 15th,
we actually have a pretty big
event here in San Francisco.
It's the Gopher Fest 2017.
MARK MANDEL: Ooh.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So it's going
to be a lot of really cool Go
talks, and we're going to
be hosting at the launch pad
here near the Google
office in San Francisco.
We'll have a link in the
show notes so you can RSVP.
I'm pretty sure the RSVP list
is going to go full really fast.
So if you're interested in
it, go find it right now.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds good.
Let me know if you
can get me a spot.
Maybe I'll come along.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
I don't think so.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
Awesome.
Francesc, thank you so much
for yet another week, and yet
another wonderful episode.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank
you so much, Mark.
And have lots of fun in Canada.
MARK MANDEL: I will, and
we'll see you all next week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: See
you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]